let's go to surya from new jersey i hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly is it
surya
yeah that's pronounced right um
i just have a question um regarding
uh okay so i i'm i'm currently in my
third week of college a freshman in
college so i wanted to ask something
about college in general like sure what
do you think is like the uh impact or
what are your thoughts on the impact of
like college students in
in elections because i i've seen a lot
of things around but i'm just wondering
your specific thoughts well i think the
impact is much smaller than it could be
because many college students don't vote
you know i think that it's a group that
every election there's these talking
points that are repeated if the youngest
voters really turn out this time it
could be an incredible blowout for the
left and then like they never do
so
i think that college age voters have the
potential to be the decision makers in
these elections if they actually turned
out but sadly they have very low voter
turnout which is disappointing to me
yeah so why do you think that's the case
though why do you think college voters
are such a turnout in such low numbers i
i mean i think that there's a couple
different things going on
for some people that age they've only
just become eligible to vote so when
things become habits we tend to just do
them more it hasn't been a habit for a
19 year old to vote so so they're not
yet in that habit and so they may not do
it number two i think there's a lot of
disaffected people that age who don't
necessarily
feel as though voting is going to have
an impact or the impact that they want
on the world around them that that's
number two and then number three people
that age also have a lot of things going
on and so in kind of a logistical sense
maybe it seems like more of an
inconvenience to go and go and vote i
think it's a lot of different things
yeah that makes sense thank you
you're gonna vote though right
yeah of course good good good all right
good well good luck at college
thank you all right very good
there's surya from new jersey with a
beautiful question